ﾆﾔｯ
ﾄﾞｫｫｫｫｫｫｫﾝ!!
痛っ⁉
はいという訳でポストです
あの～街によくポスト見かけるとおもうんですよ
でポスト～
まあこんな感じだと思うんですけどぱっと見
で、今年の夏は
普通の夏よりも違って
めっちゃくちゃ気温が高い
ポン！（効果音）
熱中症とかあぶないし
みんな暑さでちょっと頭がおかしくなってると思うんですよ！
やばくないっすか？温度が
いや温度
ほんとにやばいっす
普段、こんな格好してポストの隣にいたら
流石に間違えられないと思うんですけど
この猛暑！
はい
くそ暑いこの夏ならば
ポストの隣に僕がいても
僕をポストと間違えて
僕に手紙を投函すると思うんですよ
たし
確かにｗ
（そうきたかぁ！！！）
あはははｗ
ﾋﾟｭﾋﾟｩﾋﾟｭｩ‼（効果音）
どう変？
あ、でも遠めだとポストです。
完全にポストです！
完全にポスト？
ポストです
ポストが歩くなんてないですからね
バイバイ～
あ、ぱっと見
分からないっす
完全に一緒？
完全に一緒です
分からないっす
手紙とか出したくないですか？
ないっす
優しいポスト
はい！チーズ！
カシャ（シャッター音）
OKっす！
分かる人には分かるんですね
ポン！（効果音）
（家でパズドラやりて～）
♪~（悲しい曲）
ポスト相当凄いっす
よくやってるよ
見習いポストとしてキツイな～
てか、手紙来ないね
そもそもですよね
ダメですよ
疲れた～
ポストは休憩しないですよ
あ、手紙来たかもしれないっす
あ、着席！
♪~（感動的な曲）
もういいよね？
手紙貰ったよ！
おっ！
うまい棒ありがとうって
じゃあ、帰るか
ｗｗｗ